what's the truth of your ambition are
you ambitious first and foremost for
yourself first and foremost for your own
aggrandizement first and foremost for
what you get out of all of this or are
you ambitious first and foremost for a
cause for the company for the work for
something bigger than yourself and
what's interesting when we look in from
the outside I don't I can't measure this
but my sense from all of my research is
that people have an amazing ability
given enough time they may not know it
right up front to be able to intuit to
be able to tell what the real truth of
someone's ambition is is it about them
or is it about the cause is it about
them or is it about the company is it
about them or about something bigger
than them and how do people tell they
watch their actual decisions their
actual actions people are very attuned
to watching little cues little actions
little steps and when they see any
inconsistency it'll magnify a hundred or
a hundred thousand times and you can do
a thousand things that are consistent
with what you say you're about and do
one thing that's inconsistent and it
wipes out the thousand the trust is
built by an almost unblemished record of
consistency with what you say you're
about founded on the idea that it's not
about you I believe that that's where
the trust really begins when we look in
the social sectors the great social
secular leaders like Francis House
albino got all of these people in the
Girl Scouts to go behind what she was
trying to do they all knew it wasn't
about Francis it was about the Girl
Scouts it was about the girls and their
development and that is why she had that
trust